(lab noises and chatter)
Dan Steinberg:
This is a five-day intensive camp to teach materials science to material
science teachers taught by master teachers and Princeton professors. A hundred percent
Dan Steinberg:
of the teachers have told me how much they love this camp, how much they loved meeting
the professors, meeting each other, networking with each other and really having a hands-on
Dan Steinberg:
experience for their students that really brings an excitement for science to these students.
(music)
Sulekha Bhasin:
It's recharging my batteries completely. I'm recharged now. I'm getting
new stuff that I'm getting excited about and I hope I can bring the excitement to my kids
Sulekha Bhasin:
and they get excited about what I am teaching.
Teacher:
...these connected beads in space...
Rick Register:
We hope that by making ourselves available and as a resource we can play
a positive role. I think it's important that everybody have some general appreciation of
Rick Register:
the importance of science and technology in our daily lives.
(music)
Tom Doggart:
I'm here with the camp. I'm one of the "explainers."
I'm a metallurgist that ASM brought in here to add some real world background to the teaching.
(music)
Interviewer:
What's it like being here?
Etzel Brower:
It's like rollerblading, okay, with one foot and doing many turns, a few airborne
transitions, and then of course, an exponential up and over.
Teacher:
We cover ceramics. We cover composites, metals, polymers and also the modern materials
that are happening in the research lab today. This is our sixth year. We have trained over
Teacher:
150 teachers so far in this materials camp. These teachers have been able to reach thousands of students.
Michael Ireland:
It was because of this course that I took here several years ago that I
am now teaching, two years already, a materials science class at our school.
Michael Ireland:
You want to talk about excitement from someone who is 40 years old or someone who is 16 years old,
you take a copper penny and turn it into gold right in front of your eyes and that gets your interest.
Kerri Pettersen:
I have a lot already in the day and a half we've been here that I can
take back to my classroom and hopefully spark my students' interest and get them interested in science.
Sulekha Bhasin:
I want kids to love science. It's a science world.
Michael Ireland:
It's just science.
(music)